retrouvez ce qui est désormais un
événement à quelque chose d'autre est
connu c'est daniel balavoine à daniel
balavoine en 80 dans le journal
d'antenne 2010 avec françois mitterrand
et on va regarder ce document en
spectateur aujourd'hui je vous
demanderais daniel ensuite d'abord pour
commencer vos réflexions sur sur ce
document de nous dire comment vous le
percevez aujourd'hui aulas le journal
d'antenne 2 donc en mars 86 avec
permettez j'aimerais dire que limité
alors rien dire avant la fin de
l'émission je partageais mitterrand
parce que moi j'avais pris plein de
notes en venant dans l'autre version non
je n'aurai pas le temps je le sais déjà
que j'ai pas le temps on fait juste le
temps de mettre en colère je vais
commencer maintenant
non c'est le système de l'information
française qui fait comme ça j'aurai le
temps une minute de m'énerver juste de
m'énerver de paraître pour un petit
merdeux un petit jeune de [ __ ] la
pagaille partout
je préfère m'en aller tout de suite si
j'avais su je dois dire j'aurais dormi
beaucoup plus tard jeudi des rangs
souhaitez votre présence l'avoine dans
ce studio pour parler des problèmes de
la jeunesse pense que nous aurons eu
tort nous aurions eu le temps d'en
parler c'est être et non pas de chance y
aura les uns des autres et c'était pas
de chansons dont il était question
parler pendant 10 minutes au moins de la
sphère georges marchais dont tout le
monde se fout strictement que je vous
tienne que la jeunesse française se fout
strictement de ce que monsieur marché
faisait pendant la guerre ça lui est
complètement égal ces intérêts seraient
plus la jeunesse de savoir ce qui se
passe et comment le parti communiste en
caisse de l'argent pour le dépenser
après notamment la mairie de bagnolet
ses intérêts seraient mieux de savoir
comment gaston defferre dirige sa mairie
socialiste qui n'est pas un modèle de
société à marseille s'intéresserait plus
de savoir les jeunes français comment
monsieur raymond barre qui est arrivé il
ya cinq ans ou quatre ans je sais plus
combien de temps a dit que les salaires
ne seraient pas diminué mais qu'à
augmenter les cotisations de sécurité
sociale
c'est beaucoup plus intéressant que tout
ce que vous racontez georges marchais on
s'en fout de georges marchais il faut le
savoir de ce qu'il faisait pendant la
guerre ça nous est complètement égal le
problème de drogue de la façon dont on
le traite les ministres français on s'en
fout il n'y a jamais un jeune ministre
de l'inde de la jeunesse en france il y
en a jamais eu et c'est tous des vieux
regardez monsieur 60 enfin vous n'allez
pas me dire que c'était un homme
représentatif de la jeunesse regarder
comment je suis habillé ils sont plus
souvent habillés comme moi les jeunes
que comme monsieur soissons il faut
quand même pas rêver
tout ça ce sont des métiers j'ai encore
pris plein de notes au fur et à mesure
que vous parlez ce que je voudrais
savoir ce qui m'aurait intéressé c'est
de savoir à qui les travailleurs émigrés
paye les loyers qui paye
on a vu tout à l'heure des gens qui
disaient on paie 700 francs par mois je
voudrais savoir qu'ils encaissent de
l'argent pour louer des poubelles pareil
c'est ça que je voudrais qu'on me dise
c'est pas de savoir comment on peut
faire pour changer je voudrais qu'ils
osent tout les mois demandés 700 francs
les travailleurs immigrés pour vivre
dans des poubelles dans des taudis
ça c'est ça que j'aimerais qu'on
m'explique pas ce que moi je ne le sais
pas c'est pas la force et la formation
qui me dit je voudrais savoir pourquoi
monsieur boulin était suicidé ou s'est
suicidé ou on ne le saura jamais
pourquoi monsieur fontana et essais
signés pourquoi la terre de brebis n'a
jamais été éclairés pourquoi le juge
renaud on s'est pas ni pourquoi ni
comment il a été assassiné
j'en ai d'autres la seule chose que je
peux vous dire monsieur mitterrand j'en
profite de vous avoir parce que je suis
fier d'être là je peux vous le dire on
s'en aperçoit peut-être pas mais vous
pouvez pas imaginer ce que c'est pour un
jeune d'avoir la possibilité de parler
une minute c'est pour ça que j'avais
peur de ne pas pouvoir parler parce que
ça n'arrive jamais faut bien se mettre
en tête
ça n'arrête jamais regardé l'émission
qui a eu hier soir sur antenne 2 les
dossiers de l'écran
enfin vous n'allez pas me dire que les
mots qui étaient concernés par la
contrainte à lui abandonné c'est
vraiment la chance elle vient je sais on
était obligé côté vous exagérez
d'information je subis
pour résumer je la résume à ma manière
j'essaie de lire rapidement mes notes ce
que je vous donnais en tout cas c'est
généralement c'est un avertissement
j'ai peut-être du culot de faire ça je
suis obligé de le faire comme ça parce
que je dois faire vite
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que la
jeunesse désespère elle est profonde et
profondément désespéré parce qu'elle n'a
plus d'appuis elle ne croit plus en la
politique française
et moi je pense qu'à la règle générale
en résumant un peu bien raison ce que je
peux dire c'est que le désespoir et
mobilisateur et que lorsqu'il devient
mobilisateur il est dangereux et que ça
entraîne le terrorisme la bande à baader
et des choses comme ça et ça il faut que
les grandes personnes qui dirigent le
monde soit prévenu que les jeunes vont
finir par virer du mauvais côté parce
qu'ils n'auront plus d'autre solution
voilà je vous remercie d'avoir laissé
parler monsieur mitterrand voulait des
lieux dialoguer avec un jeune
vous l'avez écouté avec le fait que
beaucoup d'attention ce qu'il ce qui
m'intéresse beaucoup c'est que cette
façon de penser de réagi et aussi de
s'exprimer parce qu'en fait daniel
balavoine s'exprime par les cris et par
la musique ait droit de cité puissent
être entendus et donc puisse être
comprise le dia sa manière il est
responsable de ces paroles c c'est un
citoyen comme un autre mais typique et
quand je dis typique c'est parce qu'ils
représentent à mon sens des centaines de
milliers de jeunes conditions de vie ou
dans quelle banlieue
quel logement quels loisirs entrant dans
une société bétonnées qui se ferment
partout de vente avec le chômage pour
perspective pense que quelqu'un qui sait
dire et chanter c'est à dire exprimer
sous la forme de l'art drame vécu de
cette force devait être entendue lors
d'une émission de ce genre là pourquoi
condamner de la bonne part le voilà donc
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez est ce que
vous avez fait ce qui me surprend alors
là vraiment je trouve extraordinaire je
le dis sincèrement si je crois que
j'aurais pu faire la même chose hier
jeudi à un moment approprié tous les
sujets oui pratiquement j'ai dit à
d'abord là à propos de liberté dont on
va parler dans un instant avec un ami à
moi qui est un message à lancer que je
lancerai pour lui d'ailleurs j'ai
simplement une chose je parlais de
cotisations de sécurité sociale
à propos de raymond barre qu'avait dit
qu'il ne diminuerait pas les salaires
des ouvriers etc je viens d'apercevoir
que la seule l'imagination d'un
gouvernement qui était censé être prêt à
gouverner parce qu'ils ont eu le temps
de s'entraîner en 23 ans quand même
signal que moi qui ai mangé avec le
président de la république
je sais que paraît-il les équipes
étaient prêtes on s'est aperçu les
équipes ne sont pas prêtes que les
réformes ne sont pas prêtes que sur la
sécurité sociale tous les financiers je
parle pas de ça bus parce que lui c'est
mal par un financier c'est un charlot
beau dire que s'ils sont mieux le
ministre du budget le ministre du budget
oui le ministre du budget qui trouve que
c'est mieux pour combler le déficit de
la sécurité sociale d'augmenter les
cotisations d'un pour cent des ouvriers
bien entendu au lieu de taxer les
oeuvres d'art les oeuvres d'art de qui
on sait pas se demander s'il a de la
famille il adore je pense pas parce que
quand même un homme de gauche ne peut
pas avoir de la famille voyez ce que je
veux dire et cetera bon et je trouve ça
scandaleux je trouve s'agit que je peux
simplement le dire aujourd'hui
le gouvernement de gauche pour lequel
j'ai voté ou lieu essentiellement oui
vous l'avez pas quelque chose de la
compagnie t on la chambre et non ses
meetings
bah c'est pour ça que j'ai droit de
l'avion avec lui oui c'est pour quelque
chose oui depuis nom depuis la viande
depuis qu'il est président non match
prit la tête autre chose à faire oublier
le changement voilà alors que j'avais là
alors leur loi fin je dis pas que je
n'ai pas surtout on à l'abolition de la
peine de mort on à l'arrêt des
expulsions des travailleurs émigrés il
ya de bonnes choses il faut pas non plus
exagérer je parle de sujets précis parce
que là ça me réchauffe de voir ça quand
même
et je dis simplement que le gouvernement
de gauche a eu pour seule idée
d'augmenter les cotisations de sécurité
sociale pour combler le déficit c'est à
dire ça s'appelle ça porte un nom c'est
du barry smith à sa porte pas d'autre
nom c'est la même chose
et pendant ce temps là et là les
communistes ont d'ailleurs raison ça
veut pas dire je suis communiste est
loin de la maison quand même raison et
si les seuls à avoir une rectitude
d'idées à ce niveau là ils ont dit non
taxer les oeuvres d'art j'ai mon cahier
devant moi c'est parce que je ne voulais
pas de le dire des bêtises voilà on va
passer là dessus je voulais aussi qu'on
arrête de faire une confusion salage je
débite un petit peu parce que par
exemple moi je suis souvent accusés de
richesse par accusés parce que les gens
sont beaucoup plus gentil que les
gouvernants finalement bien souvent on
dit de moi par exemple que je suis riche
que les chanteurs sont riches ce pied
pour ceux qui marchent en tout cas une
vérité je le dis honnêtement on gagne
beaucoup d'argent souvent pas pendant
longtemps mais c'est vrai que quand on
en gagne ou on gagne beaucoup mais je
dis simplement une chose c'est qu'il ne
faut pas confondre les riches salariés
dont je fais partie
c'est à dire que je peux être amené à
être au chômage demain matin et les
riches possédants alors je vais penser
au niveau de la fiscalité je trouve
normal moi de payer beaucoup plus
d'impôts que un smicard ce que je ne
veux pas et ça je le dis avec autorité
parce que j'ai mis un bulletin de vote à
gauche donc je dis avec autorité à
monsieur fabius qui est un homme
extrêmement agaçant pour ça extrêmement
de menteur qu'ils arrêtent de faire de
la démagogie
surtout entre le tour d'élection le
deuxième tour des élections
présidentielle et les élections
législatives
qu'ils arrêtent de mentir en disant
qu'ils font payer les riches
les riches sont partis on le sait quelqu
un de la cgt est en train de dénoncer
nous payons nourish salariés non pas
pour les pauvres salariés
mais pour les fraudeurs il faut qu'on me
dise ça il faut que ce soit dit quitte à
ce que je chante pas ma chanson tant pis
nous les riches salariés tant pis en
élisant l'habitude ils me voient trop à
la télé pour ça les riches salariés
payent pour les riches fraudeurs c'est
ça qu'il faut dire et arrêter de faire
la démagogie avec c'est de raconter des
mensonges parce que c'est honteux de
mentir on voulait un changement et
voulait surtout un changement de vérité
sert on veut entendre des choses vraies
et simple je préfère l'avoir de l'heure
et fabius qui me disent écoutez vous
payer parce que il ya machin là on vient
de le voir encore passer la douane avec
les mallettes on s'excuse on est obligé
de vous demander un peu plus que ça ça
sera clair que les gens le sachent
est ce que quand vous avez vu françois
mitterrand sur le plateau d' rejoint
l'antenne de ya un peu plus d'un an les
prix pour le petit jésus ce tir qui peut
multiplier les pains faire la pêche
miraculeuse tout changer est ce que vous
croyez franchement non non mais
franchement je suis pas un changement de
majorité au fait je dis simplement qu'il
est hors de question de changer tout du
jour au lendemain mais que quand on a 23
ans pour se préparer que quand on
prétend avoir des équipes prête à
gouverner qu'on s'aperçoit qu'en fait
c'est un pugilat entre chevènement
rocard de faire tous ces gens là qui ont
tout étant dans différents tickets se
tape sur la gueule pour avoir les postes
alors qu'on pensait que tout le monde
était prêt à s'entendre pour gouverner
je dis que ça c'est anormal
je ne veux pas de révolution la
révolution l'a fait pas un changement de
gouvernement en charge au gouvernement
la révolution l'a fait comme en 1789 en
faisant la révolution pas en changeant
fait une révolution on la fait pas j'ai
personnellement la liberté plus de 300
il en faut non mais j'aurais juste finir
ce que ce que je disais parce que là ça
fait rien la sécurité sociale
et toutes ces choses là ce sont des
réformes quand 23 ans des gens de gauche
avait le temps de préparer et que
normalement le lendemain le 11 mai 1981
monsieur fabius monsieur de l'heure et
tous ces gens là devait dire voilà ce
que nous allons faire tout de suite et
pas en 83 tout de suite pour la sécurité
sociale est tout de suite pour la
fiscalité ça veut dire que non contente
pas être prêt en plus il manque d'idées
on est là pour la randonnée c'est pour
ça qu'on a voté si vous avez besoin d'un
coup de main
[Musique]